à pâques c'est la tradition on cache des
oeufs en chocolat alors du chocolat
d'accord c'est la fête mais pourquoi des
eaux
et bien parce qu'autrefois les poules ne
recommence et apprendre qu'au printemps
quand il ya davantage de lumière durant
l'antiquité le fêtait d'oka symbole de
renaissance et de renouveau
on en a même trouvé dans des tombes
sumérienne une ancienne civilisation du
moyen-orient pour accompagner le défunt
dans sa nouvelle vie mais si l'oeuf est
devenu incontournable en cette période
de l'année c'est parce qu'autrefois
l'église en interdisaient la
consommation durant karen 40 jours
pendant lesquels les boules continuer à
pondre le jour de pâques
camp lejeune prenait fin on offrait des
oeufs symbole de renouveau et de
résurrection du christ mais aussi pour
vider les réserves et remplir les
estomacs l'oeuf le vrai est un aliment
très riche en protéines
deux correspondants steaks de 100
grammes au chocolat il n'a pas l'air mal
non plus une vraie capsules de les
confiner aller à demain n'oubliez pas
nous sommes confinés
nous on reste en lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain